[Music]  people gearing up for Easter this  weekend and here's the problem though  thinking about this with the economy in  rough shape a lot of people out there  have to stick to a very tight budget  when buying Easter candy and gifts not a  lot of people have money right now so  here with some money saving Easter tips  once again our prop master bill tall  bill take some baked beans spray-paint  them boom jelly beans  here's another tip from bill bill take a  bunch of unpaid parking tickets  just to get the shredder boom Easter  grass  [Applause]  [Music]  take a styrofoam peanut stick a beak on  it boom marshmallow peak another one  [Music]  take a pair of slippers stick them to  your head  [Applause]  take a beard put it on your face  boom he is risen pick up a hooker on  Easter boom  Easter hooker  [Music]  don't cheer Easter hooker